la semaine de la mobilité a lieu tous
les ans du 16 au 22 septembre
c'est un événement européen pour
permettre à tous de se déplacer
autrement auto-stop covoiturage vélo
électrique des alternatives mises en
valeur dans la vallée de chevreuse par
le parc naturel en collaboration avec
les communes et associations
on a mis l'accent cette année
essentiellement sur le vélo et donc pour
ça on a organisé pour la première année
une convergence à vélo qui a eu le 15
septembre dernier c'était un dimanche
ensoleillé où on a accueilli plus d'une
soixantaine de cyclistes qui ont tous
convergé vers la vie du
perray-en-yvelines donc l'idée c'était
de partir de plusieurs points de départ
sur le parc depuis jouars pontchartrain
rambouillet et saint rémy les chevreuse
et tous ces cyclistes se retrouvait donc
un même point à l'arrivée donc et
plusieurs animations autour du vélo
comme
des démos souci de la restauration de
l'atelier de réparation de vélos
également une après midi qui est un
véritable succès et qui semble avoir plu
aux habitants venus spécialement pour
l'événement découvert de beaux paysages
des senteurs rencontrer des gens sympas
est à refaire nous avons utilisé les
pistes cyclables y sont actuellement sur
le parcours vers la forêt de rambouillet
pour continuer dans cette lancée on a
organisé également le 18 septembre une
journée plutôt à destination des
familles autour du vélo toujours là
c'était à l'aiguillage à saint rémy les
chevreuse ou face à la gare où on a
organisé des tests de vélos à assistance
électrique également du vo smoothie
aussi qu'ils étaient présents donc les
gens pouvaient pédaler et créer
fabriquer leur jus de fruits directement
sur le vélo nous l'avons sportive on a
ramené notre bissy mixeur c'est un vélo
qui est relié un blender
les deux sont deux objets qui étaient
usagers on les a rassemblés pour faire
un un seul objet est
leur donner une deuxième vie et donc
après l'effort du pédalage et le
réconfort du smoothie que ce soit des
convergences que soit le vélo pour aller
au travail ou pour faire du loisir c'est
quand même la base quand même prendre du
plaisir
une occasion pour sensibiliser sur tout
ce qui est des déplacements à vélo
comment se comporter sur la route pour
être vraiment en sécurité quand on
utilise le vélo au quotidien pour ça le
système de baromètre des villes
cyclables est menée en ce moment en fait
il s'agit d'apprécier en fait quel est
le système vélo de votre ville s'il
existe d'abord et puis ensuite de voir
quel est votre satisfaction par rapport
à ce système vélo chaque ville chaque
municipalité chaque candidat aux
municipales chaque association locale et
bien pourra s'inspirer de ré des
résultats de ce baromètre qui sont des
résultats extrêmement complet parlant
pour savoir ce qu'il faut faire mais la
semaine n'est pas terminée les cyclistes
sont de nouveau attendus ce week-end
pour les journées du patrimoine pour
d'autres sorties découvertes en vélo
[Musique]